you guys got tattoos together we did  yeah yeah she's my queen I don't know if  you can see it yeah at four you got a  very faint tattoo which I think was you  know you didn't want to really show up  right no I was I told my mom I was like  I'm gonna get a tattoo she was like  don't put it anywhere I can see it and I  was like I'm getting on my forearm and  so we kind of compromise and I go to  impeach but it's the date thing that if  you got a peach-colored tattoo it's a  peach tattoo that's like exact color I  would get I would get a piece that dude  it would just look like more freckles  Jinja problems yes ginger problem it's  the date that we both bought Game of  Thrones on oh that's nice  so you both got the same you both got  the same tattoo I can see nothing  okay I'm sorry you know hey they might  adjust me why I think that you I think  that's what you artists just lied to you  oh yeah oh there it's in a very faint  peach see anything  you